elon musk has been a republican for less
than 48 hours and already they are me
tooing him that's right already they are
accusing him of sex crimes
i think that's a new record
elon musk has been around
for half a century now
he has been in public life since the
late 1990s he has been prominent in
public life for what 20 years now
and just now just
24 hours after announcing that he's
become a republican the establishment
media run a shocking story that six
years ago elon musk propositioned a
masseuse or something
elon actually predicted that this would
happen a couple of days ago he said
expect the political attacks against me
to escalate in the coming months
and because the establishment
propagandists are so predictable we get
this first one almost immediately
all of a sudden for whatever reason
whatever reason who knows
six years after the alleged incident
this poor beleaguered masseuse has just
seen fit to bring this traumatic
experience to light just coincidentally
while elon is in the midst of a hostile
takeover of a major speech platform on
an explicitly anti-leftist political
platform
what are the odds what are the odds i
have a rule in politics
i do not take seriously
any allegation against long-time public
figures
especially against political figures and
especially in heated political moments
that concerns events that supposedly
took place
years prior
the reason is one if the allegations
were legit they likely would have come
out
years prior they would have come out in
the past but also two
because the allegations are so
obviously cynical so obviously
opportunistic at least
even in the unlikely event that whatever
is alleged did actually happen
it is only coming out now to shut the
accused person up or to intimidate the
accused person or to bully the accused
person or to stop him from affecting
whatever kind of political change he's
trying to bring about
in the past when the establishment had
more credibility these sorts of
campaigns worked
today i'm not so sure that they do if
anything frankly i think they might have
the opposite effect
i was previously somewhat on the fence
about elon musk i like the twitter stuff
i like the trolling don't love plugging
your brain into the matrix so i don't
know i was a little bit on the fence
now that he is being hit with some
cynical sex allegation by the worst
people on earth by the news media and
the political hacks in the establishment
i am far more likely to support him
in a world of censorship and media
manipulation it can be hard to judge a
man by his words and even by his actions
but you can still judge a man by his
enemies and right now elon has all the
right ones right now go to
goodranchers.com
knowles you should do this just
generally this would be a good idea if
that were all i were going to tell you
today about good ranchers which brings
top quality meat to your door whenever
you want it
but today's even crazier because when
you place your order with code knowles k
w l e s you will get two pounds of free
wagyu beef which is my favorite thing
that good ranchers puts out and i love
all of their stuff i love the better
than organic chicken i love the new york
strip steaks i love all of it but my
favorite is that wagyu beef so you can
get two pounds right now of the wagyu
beef just for free you can save 25
per month when you subscribe off of
every single box for life and speaking
of for life we've got inflation going on
through our economy right now record
highs you can lock in your price for
meat for life you can inflation proof
your grocery shopping head on over to
goodranchers.com knowles or use code
knowles right now to claim two pounds of
free wagyu burgers and lock in your
subscription price if you do not buy the
meat in your house tell the person who
does to grab two pounds of free american
wagyu beef today before it's gone promo
code knowles goodranchers.com
knowles the elon sexual harassment
allegation has so
many layers to it
so what the libs are claiming now
is what all of elon's political
opponents are claiming which is to say
the libs
they're saying
listen the only reason that elon warned
people
that he there were going to be a lot of
political attacks against him the only
reason he came out as a republican the
only reason he's championing free speech
and all this is because he knew
he knew that these allegations were
going to come out so he got ahead of the
story
uh okay
yeah maybe the timing is a little
coincidental for me because it's not as
though elon musk woke up one day and
just out of the blue said i'm a
republican now
and then this the allegations hit then
you could imagine okay maybe he was
tipped off that the allegations were
going to come out that business insider
was going to run this story and so he
just pulled a publicity stun
but elon has been setting the stage for
this
for
well over a month now more than well
more than a month
and he's been paddling around with the
babylon bee and he's been cozying up to
conservatives for a very very long time
you're telling me that business insider
was just working on this story the whole
time and and that elon musk is now
putting 44 billion on the table
and and opening himself up to the
securities and exchange commission
opening himself up to all sorts of
political attacks
to get ahead of this story about
propositioning a masseuse i don't buy
that i don't buy that for one second so
there's obviously the political layer to
it
at the most superficial layer this is
about a woman who's seen the light and
says she needs to accuse elon musk six
years after something very vaguely
insinuated maybe happened
then the deeper level is this is
obviously about politics this is
obviously because elon is going against
the liberal establishment so they're
going to turn all the guns on him and
they're going to use their most frequent
method which is me tooing him okay
there's actually a deeper level
potentially even than that there's a
story that came out last night from the
twitter account unusual wales which
posts
financial activity and they pointed out
that
coincidentally the day after this
business insider story on elon musk was
published there was a large put option
that was expiring so there was a
the day after the story was published
there was an opportunity
for a big investor to bet against
the tesla
share price
there was an opportunity and it was that
was it that that was going to be the day
that it was going to happen
that
the that someone could make a lot of
money if the tesla share price went down
a lot of money an unusual amount of
money
and then just coincidentally the day
before that's to happen business insider
drops this story it gets even crazier
because the ceo of business insider has
been accused of securities fraud and i
think barred from the industry
business insider did the same thing with
barstool right you remember i think it
was business insider that broke that
story someone in the press broke that
story about about dave portnoy and
barstool sports and they they meet him
as well
and oddly enough
the same
situation was happening there was an
opportunity the following day to make a
ton of money if
the
price of bar stool went down
so what exactly is going on here now
unusual whales did not make any specific
allegations here whether against
business insider or anyone else just
observing that the timing is a little
coincidental in the same way that the
political watchers were observing that
the timing was a little coincidental of
these allegations
so too the financial insiders were
looking at that as well when you're
trying to figure out what is this about
and
you've got in one place
virtue
and then in the next place ideology and
then the next place politics and then
the next place money what is this about
this big new political event
you're usually safe for betting on the
last two
okay a lot of times what happens is the
whoa corporations or the hack
politicians they will
feign virtue they will signal virtue
they will
they will speak in terms of ideology but
what a lot of it comes down to is cold
hard jockeying for power and cold hard
cash seems to be what's going on here i
don't think it'll work though
it might hurt him i mean any allegation
is damaging that's why people still lob
them but i don't think it'll really hurt
elon with his base i think we see
through this kind of stuff frankly
i am more inclined to support him now
that i see that the entire media
establishment are going after him think
okay well he's got the right enemies
he's got my enemies so i guess he can't
be all bad i'm glad you like that clip
now
very important you've got to smash and
ring and click and do the doodad and hit
the gizmo and subscribe to the michael
knowles show you will get all of the
notifications and if youtube doesn't
give you all the notifications head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcast for free subscribe do it right
now i'll wait
okay good subscribe the michael knowles
show leave a five star review see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]